How do you pronounce that name right there? Chaplitsky. One more time. Chaplitsky. Okay. That is the answer. Okay. Thank you, Ramona.
那个名字到底怎么读？Chaplitsky。再来一次。Chaplitsky。好的。这就是答案。好的。谢谢你，雷蒙娜。
Well, it's official. Thank you, dear. I'll let Evan know he needs to update it to that. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 156, recorded on November 13th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Richard Feldman, creator of the brand new Rock Programming Language and host of the Software Unscripted podcast. In today's episode, we chat with him about the last edition of the Strange Loop Conference, virtual versus in-person conferences, and more. Richard, can I ask, have you been, like, you seem to be in a closet is, is everything okay? Are you?
好吧，这下官方盖章了。谢谢亲爱的。我会告诉埃文，他需要把发音更新成这样。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，我是主持人康纳，今天是 2023 年 11 月 13 日，我和我的联席主持布莱斯一起，采访了全新编程语言 Rock 的创造者、Software Unscripted 播客的主持人理查德·费尔德曼。在今天的节目中，我们将和他聊聊最后一届 Strange Loop 会议、线上与线下会议的对比等等。理查德，我想问一下，你一直在，怎么说呢，你好像在一个储藏室里？一切都还好吗？你这是……
Yes. This is, this is my recording studio. Doesn't everybody's look like this? I used to record from a closet. So, you know? Yeah.
是的。这是我的录音室。难道大家的录音室不长这样吗？我以前就是在储藏室录音的。所以呢？对吧。
Oh, so what happened was, uh, I was on a podcast once and, uh, the room I'm normally in has like an air conditioner unit next to it. And it turned on and someone was like, what is that horrible loud noise? And I was like,
哦，事情是这样的，我以前上过一个播客，我平时呆的那个房间旁边有一个空调机组。结果它突然启动了，有人就问：“那是什么可怕的巨响？”我说……
Oh, sorry. And they're like, well, do you have any place you could go that's like just you know small space nothing and this is like the the place they're like oh the audio quality is great in here you should you should always record from here so i was like ah cool so now i always record from here makes sense bryce doesn't know much about audio quality so no but i i do know that air conditioner bad from the one time that i recorded half of a talk um and not like the first half of the last half like you know some slides with the ac on some slides with the ac off and then later realized my mistake and had
哦，抱歉。他们就说：“呃，你有没有什么地方可以去，就是那种你知道的、很小的、什么都没有的空间？”然后这里就是他们说的那个地方，他们说：“哦，这里的音质太棒了，你以后都应该在这里录音。”所以我就想：“啊，太酷了，那我以后就在这里录音吧。”这就说得通了，布莱斯对音质一窍不通，所以……不，不过我的确知道空调是个祸害，因为我曾经有一次录制了半场演讲，不是前半场，是后半场，你知道的，有些幻灯片是在开着空调的情况下录的，有些幻灯片是在关着空调的情况下录的，后来才发现自己犯了错，不得不重新去把所有开着空调时的幻灯片重新录了一遍。好吧。总之，照例我们已经深入探讨了。我不知道这个词的时态用得对不对，但我们就这么着吧。那我先做一个简短的介绍。我们在之前的播客里已经提到过他好几次了。确实提过。通常是在提到 Rock 的语境下，这显然是理查德的——对于那些业内人士来说，理查德的……
to go through and re-record all of the AC slides. All right. Well, as per usual, we've dove. I don't know if that's the right tense of that word, but we're going to stick with it. So I will give a brief introduction. We've mentioned him several times on the podcast before. We did. On the context of typically bringing up Rock, which is obviously Richard's. For those that are in the know uh richards
等等，理查德的……
programming language uh but actually do you still work for no red ink uh not as of uh april so now i work at vendor v-e-n-d-r okay i think i recall that because i recall in a talk you mentioned that you were i think switching companies and part of that was basically you were going to be working if not full-time on rock you were going to be working, if not full-time on Rock, you were going to be spending a large percentage of your time working on Rock there. Yes. So works at Vendor now.
编程语言。不过话说回来，你现在还在 NoRedInk 工作吗？从四月份起就不在了。我现在在 Vendor 工作，字母是 V-E-N-D-r。好的，我想我记得这个，因为我记得你在一次演讲中提到过，你好像要换公司了，其中一部分原因基本上是，如果你不是全职做 Rock 的话，那你也会花很大一部分时间在那里从事 Rock 的开发。是的。所以他现在在 Vendor 工作。
There was a yes there that I may or may not have just cut off. But, I mean, before working at Vendor, you worked at NoRedInk, which is probably because of the sort of evangelism that you do, giving talks about functional programming, one of the most well-known Elm shops. And you have a podcast now that's been going on for, I think, 60 or 70 episodes, Software Unscripted. And you've given, as I just mentioned, a bunch of very highly regarded and highly viewed talks. My personal favorite, I think because we were chatting about this a week ago, my favorite is why functional programming isn't the norm. And it's got about like a million and a half views on YouTube.
刚才有个“是的”，我可能不小心给剪掉了。不过，在去 Vendor 工作之前，你在 NoRedInk 工作过，那可能是因为你做的那些技术推广，做关于函数式编程的演讲，那可是最知名的 Elm 公司之一。你现在还有一个播客，好像已经做了 60 或 70 期了，叫 Software Unscripted。正如我刚才提到的，你发表过一堆备受推崇和关注的演讲。我个人最喜欢的，可能是因为我们一周前刚聊过这个，我最喜欢的是“为什么函数式编程没有成为常态”。它在 YouTube 上大约有一百五十万的观看量。
So link will be in the show notes if you want to go and check that out. Yeah, I mean, lots of stuff we can talk about today. I think we're going to spend a little bit of time chatting about the last edition of Strangeloop because I happen to know that you were at that installation. And I think you've been at a number of those installations. Almost all of them. Almost all of them.
所以如果你想去看看的话，链接会放在本期节目的简介里。是的，我是说，今天我们可以聊的东西很多。我想我们会花一点时间聊聊最后一届 Strange Loop，因为据我所知，你参加了那一届。而且我想你参加过其中的很多届。几乎每一届。几乎每一届。
Almost all of them. Yeah. Well, let's just, and don't worry, listener, we will get to Rock. That's ROC, cutting edge, nascent programming language. We love programming languages on this podcast. We do. And we even love more the, you know, the nascent in there, you know, adolescence. I don't know if you would say it's in its adolescence, but Carbon, Hilo, we love all the languages that aren't even languages yet. I
几乎每一届。是的。好吧，我们就——听众朋友们别担心，我们等会儿会聊到 Rock。那是 ROC，一门前沿的、新兴的编程语言。我们在这个播客里非常喜欢编程语言。确实喜欢。而且我们更喜欢那种，你知道的，处于萌芽期、处于青春期的语言。我不知道你会不会说它正处于青春期，不过 Carbon、Hilo，我们喜欢所有那些甚至还不算真正语言的语言。我……
think, I think Rock is a lot further, but before we get to Rock, if you want to add anything to that off the cuff introduction, and then maybe we can chat a bit about all the times you've been to Strange Loop and how the last one was, I'll throw it over to you and we can go from there. Yeah, well, thanks. That was a, that was a lovely introduction. Yeah, we can talk about Strange Loop. So I used to live in St. Louis when the first Strange Loop happened. So I've been to almost all of them. I think I went to 10 of them out of the 12 that there were. I missed two. The first one I missed because I just moved out of St. Louis and it seemed silly to fly back after I just left. And the second one, my son was going to be born right around there. So that was not going to work. Wife wouldn't let you,
我觉得，我觉得 Rock 已经发展得成熟多了。不过在我们聊到 Rock 之前，如果你想对刚才那个即兴介绍补充点什么，然后我们可以稍微聊聊你参加 Strange Loop 的种种经历以及最后一届的情况，我就把话筒交给你，我们从那儿开始聊起。好的，谢谢。那是一个非常棒的介绍。是的，我们可以聊聊 Strange Loop。第一届 Strange Loop 举办的时候，我住在圣路易斯。所以几乎每一届我都参加了。在总共 12 届里，我大概去了 10 届。我错过了两届。我错过了第一届是因为我刚搬离圣路易斯，刚走又飞回来感觉挺傻的；至于第二届，我儿子差不多在那前后出生。所以那是行不通的。你妻子不让你去……
wife, wife wouldn't let you go. Oh, that wasn't even a conversation. I wasn't like, Hey, do you think it'd be all right? Like, no, it's just like, that's not, I mean, cause it was like, you know, the due date was around then. So, you know, it might've worked out, but it might've extremely not worked out. So I didn't feel like rolling the dice on that one having a conversation with rich hickey oh my wife just uh hang on i gotta i gotta go because i am a dad now understandable um yeah strange loops really great i'm gonna miss it uh i don't know what what do you want to chat about strange loop wise i mean so i was thinking about going to the last one it was just at the tail so it is you know middle of november right now this took place i think it was the
你妻子不让你去。哦，那甚至都不是个商量的问题。我当时并没有说：“嘿，你觉得我去行吗？”不，根本不是这样，因为预产期就在那个时候。所以，也许最后能成，但也有可能极其搞砸。所以我不打算在那件事上碰运气，去跟里奇·希基（Rich Hickey）对话：“哦，亲爱的，等等，我得走了，因为我现在是个当爹的人了。”可以理解。嗯，是的，Strange Loop 真的很棒，我会想念它的。我不知道，关于 Strange Loop 你想聊点什么？我是说，我在考虑去最后一届，它正好在尾声——所以现在是 11 月中旬，这届大会举行的时间，我记得是 9 月的倒数第二周或者最后一周，大概也就是两个月前吧。我想我是因为月初有个婚礼，而且我要去地球的另一端待几个星期，所以才决定不去的。不过这些年来我真的看过了太多精彩的演讲。我是说，回想当年，Strange Loop 曾有一个名为“新兴编程语言”的专场，我记得最后这几年好像没有了，但你可以去找出一些语言的演讲，它们实际上已经算得上是……
second last week or maybe the last week of september so just like roughly two months ago and i think it was because i had a wedding at the beginning of the month and i was going to be on the other side of the world for a couple weeks weeks that I decided not to go, but I've just seen so many good talks over the years. I mean, I think back in the day, Strangeloop used to have a track called the Emerging Programming Languages track, which I don't think they had, you know, the last couple of years, but like you can go and find some talks of like languages that are actually kind of, you know, I wouldn't say mainstream, but like pretty popular and have like big user bases that back then were a lot smaller. So
嗯，我不会说是主流，但算是相当受欢迎，拥有庞大用户基础的语言，而当年它们的规模要小得多。所以，不管怎样，我很好奇，这一届办得怎么样？我看过其中的一些演讲。我们会把一些我最喜欢的链接放出来。我是说，埃文——我永远也发不准他的姓。他的发音是 Chaplicky。好吧，关于这个我其实有个有趣的故事。我第一次见到埃文的时候——埃文创造了 Elm，当时我住在旧金山，他也是。我当时刚通过一篇博客文章开始尝试这门语言，我非常非常喜欢它，然后我发现他也住在旧金山，于是我想：哦，不如我在 Twitter 上私信他一下，看看能不能一起吃个午餐，因为我真的很喜欢他的语言。所以我和他见了面，我问了他那个相同的问题，我说：“那么，你的姓到底应该怎么读？”他说：“我也不确定。”在能够得到的各种回答中，我完全没料到会是这个。所以他说：“嗯，显然，如果你是波兰人——这个姓氏就源自那里——他们会说……”
anyways, I'm just curious, like, how was how was, you know, this last version? I've seen a bunch of the talks. We'll link some of my favorites. I mean, Evan, I can never pronounce his last name. It's so he pronounces it Chaplicky. I okay, I have a funny story about that, though. So the first time I met Evan so Evan created Elm and so I was living in San Francisco so was he I had just started trying out this language based on a blog post and I really really liked it and I found out that he also lived in
而他最近才刚发现这一点，他说：“但我从小到大，我父母总是说 Chaplicky，所以我不确定什么才是正确的，就像……”
San Francisco and I was like oh let me just like DM him on Twitter and just see if like hey you know I'd love to just like grab lunch with you and I really like your language so I met him in person I asked him that same question I was like so how are you supposed to pronounce your last name and he's like i'm not sure what of all the answers i could have gotten i was not expecting that one and so he said well apparently like if you're polish which is where the name comes from they would say like
而他最近才刚发现这一点，他说：“但我从小到大，我父母总是说 Chaplicky，所以我不确定什么才是正确的，就像什么是更正确的？”但是在经过一些……他说：“算了，我还是入乡随俗吧。”这个名字是怎么拼的？C-Z-A-P-L-I-C。C-Z-A-P-L-I-C。C-Z-A-P-L-I-C。
and he just recently discovered this and he's like but i always grew up my parents always said chaplicky so i'm not sure like what's correct like he's like, but I always grew up, my parents always said Chaplicky. So I'm not sure, like, what's correct? Like, what's more correct? But after some, you know, he's like, I'm just going to stick with it. How is this name spelled? C-Z-A-P-L-I-C. C-Z-A-P-L-I-C. C-Z-A-P-L-I-C.
最后还有一个 I。-A-P-I-C。最后还有一个 I。哦，布莱斯在做这个。他的女朋友是波兰人。等等。是 C-Z-A-P-I-C-I。让我把它打在聊天框里。只要，好吧。把它打在聊天框里。
And there's an I at the end there.-A-P-I-C. There's an I at the end there. Oh, here's what Bryce is doing. His girlfriend is Polish. Wait a minute. It's C-Z-A-P-I-C-I. Let me put it in the chat. Just so, okay. Put it in the chat.
这还是头一遭。这绝对是头一遭。我不确定雷蒙娜的声音以前有没有在播客里出现过。布莱斯经常提到雷蒙娜，但我想……埃文·恰普利基（Evan Chaplicki）。所以那是埃文自己说的，但现在我们要知道了。亲爱的，我们需要你的技能。那个名字到底怎么读？Chaplicki。还有一个地方？Chaplitsky。再来一次。
This is a first. This is a first. I'm not sure if Ramona has actually, her voice has ever been on the podcast. A lot of times Bryce will refer to Ramona, but I think Evan Chaplicki. So that's from what Evan has said, but now we're going to get. Sweetie, we need your skills. How do you pronounce that name right there? Chaplicki. One more there? Chaplitsky. One more time.
Chaplitsky。好的。这就是答案。谢谢你，雷蒙娜。好吧，这下官方盖章了。谢谢亲爱的。我会告诉埃文，他需要把发音更新成那样。嗯，我是说，你做到了，他发现波兰语的发音
Chaplitsky. Okay. That is the answer. Thank you, Ramona. Well, it's official. Thank you, dear. I'll let Evan know he needs to update it to that. Well, I mean, you did that his he discovered that the polish pronunciation
听起来和刚才那个非常相似。所以，从技术上讲，我觉得这其实非常普遍，那就是很多姓氏的英式发音，对它们的实际发音来说并不准确。比如我的姓，我们读作 Hoekstra，但在荷兰语里发音大不相同。我甚至都不打算试着去念它了。所以，每当有人说，我觉得我的校长，他叫我 Hoekstra，我就想，好吧，我知道这读错了，但我也可能在念错。所以这其实没什么大不了的。
it sounds very similar to what that was right there so um yeah and i mean technically i think that's very common though is that the anglo you know pronunciation of a lot of last names is not you know accurate to whatever you know it actually like i think technically my last name we pronounce it hoekstra but in Dutch, it's much different. I'm not even going to attempt to try and say it. So, you know, whenever someone said, like, I think my principal, he called me Hoekstra. And I was like, well, I know that's wrong, but like, I'm also probably saying it wrong. So it's like, it's not a big deal.
对的。我觉得这非常美国化：坚信别人必须按照我们发错的方式去把东西发错。这就好像，“这不是官方发音，但你知道吗？现在你得按我们的方式来读。”是的。这非常非常……
Right. I think it's a very American thing to insist that other people mispronounce things the way we mispronounce them. It's like, this is not the official pronunciation, but you know what? Now you need to pronounce it our way. Yes. That is a very, very,
一种西方人的做法。不管怎样，有很多精彩的演讲。其中一场是埃文做的，而且他好像已经很久没有做过演讲了。所以，我看到一些评论说：
uh, a Western kind of thing. Anyways, lots of great talks. One was given by Evan and I don't think he had given one in a while. So, I mean, I saw some comments on it that said,
“哦，天哪，埃文终于重出江湖了，这又是一场他的精彩演讲，”因为他过去做过很多出色的演讲。不管怎样，总体的感想如何？最后一届办得怎么样？有什么……“埃文终于重出江湖了，这又是一场他的精彩演讲，”因为他过去做过很多出色的演讲。不管怎样，总体的感想如何？最后一届办得怎么样？有什么……你觉得很棒的演讲，或者你看到的精彩演讲，你知道的，因为我听了大量的播客，我觉得没有哪一个真的做过 Strange Loop 的回顾总结，所以我们不需要做一个全面的回顾，但我原本以为某些函数式编程的播客会提一下：“哦，这是最后一届了，这里有一些你该去看看的精彩演讲。”所以这就是我的尝试，想从某个人那里得到一个评价。去了吗？嗯，所以，从函数式编程的角度来看，我随手能记起来的、在会上做演讲的两个主要演讲者，至少是属于函数式编程社群的，当然一个是埃文，另一个是大卫·诺兰（David Nolan），他长期以来一直是 ClojureScript 的负责人。但是他的演讲——他们两个人的演讲都不是关于函数式编程的。埃文的是关于开源编程语言的资助模型的，而大卫的是关于 Go 的。所以，抱歉，不是那门语言。可能还有其他一些我记不清了，但我猜这两个之所以让我印象深刻，是因为……
Oh, you know, finally Evan has come out of the woodworks and another great talk from him because he's given a lot of good ones in the past. Anyways, just like overall thoughts. How was the last one? Any, you know finally evan has come out of the woodworks and another great talk from him because he's given a lot of good ones in the past anyways just like overall thoughts how was the last one any you know of your talks that you or talks that you saw that you thought were great or you know and and just sort of you know i because i listened to a ton of podcasts and i don't think any of them really did like a strange loop recap so we don't need to do like a full-blown recap but i was expecting some of the functional podcasts to like mention that oh it was the last one and here's
我的计划是，既然这是最后一届 Strange Loop，我主要只是想见很多我知道以后可能很久都无法在现实中见到的人，因为我们以后每年都不会再有 Strange Loop 了，而平时我通常都是靠它来和大家叙旧的。所以在那个会议上，我非常卖力地进行“走廊社交”（hallway tracking）。这并不难做到，因为实际上，甚至在我到达会场之前，当我还在酒店大堂准备走过去的时候，我就开始认出熟人了，然后打招呼：“哦，嘿，嘿，嘿……”
some good talks you should go watch so that's that's my attempt here uh to get you know a review from someone was there well so i mean functional wise i mean that the two main presenters at least that i remember offhand that gave uh talks who were sort of in the functional community would be evan of course and then also david nolan, who's been like the lead for closure script for a long time. But his talk, neither their talks were about functional programming. I mean, Evans was about the like funding models for open source programming languages. And David's was about go. So like, sorry, not the language. And there may have been some others that i'm not remembering but i guess the reason that those stuck out at me is um kind of my plan because
就这样和大家打招呼叙旧。我们一路走过去，又遇到更多人，然后开始叙旧。基本上在第一的大部分时间里，都是马不停蹄地和大家聊天、叙旧、看看大家都在忙些什么。然后，我想我去听了几个演讲。不过对我来说，这就是会议的主要体验。所以，如果你在寻找……那里还有一个非常酷的艺术装置，也是我的一个朋友做的，或者他和另一个人一起制作的——查尔斯·康斯托克（Charles Comstock），向查尔斯致敬！
it was the last strange loop was i mainly just wanted to see a lot of people that i'm i know i'm not going to get to see in person you know uh for maybe a long time because we won't have strange loop every year which is like normally what I would catch up with them. So I hallway tracked very hard at that conference. And that wasn't hard to do because, I mean, basically, actually even before I got to the venue, like when I was in the hotel lobby about to walk over, I just started recognizing people and like say, oh, hey, hey, hey,
他制作了一个东西，类似于 Strange Loop 的无限大（infinity）标志。他基本上把它的设计成内部布满了可以通过编程控制的 LED 灯，他们带了一个小笔记本电脑，还有一个小的 MIDI 键盘，所以你可以弹奏一些东西，实时看到 LED 灯发生变化，并尝试输入一些小算法来制作动画，这样……
and just like talking to people and catching up. And like we walked over and they ran into more people and started catching up with them. And it was pretty much nonstop, like talking to people and catching up and, you know, seeing what people are up to for most of the first day. Uh, and then I, I guess I went to a couple of talks. Um, but I mean, for me, that was the sort of the main experience of the conference. So I guess if you're looking for, um, there was a really cool art installation, uh, also by a friend of mine, uh, or he, he made it with one other person, uh, Charles Comstock, shout out to Charles.
你就可以制作出色彩图案，或者让某种设计沿着循环流动。真的很酷。但总的来说，我——抱歉，我可能要让你失望了，但我如果说有一场演讲真正让我大开眼界的话……埃文的演讲是我的最爱，但我并没有看太多演讲，因为我忙着和别人聊天。嗯，这很符合常理。我参加过很多会议，在那里你本来有演讲日程，然后你会发现自己在和某个与你不在同一个城市、而且以后也没机会继续你们刚才那场对话的人聊起天来。因此，有一半的时间，你最后往往会变成：“你想不想去什么地方吃点东西？”然后你们原本 50 分钟的走廊对话就变成了一个三小时的午餐或晚餐，接着又演变成其他人也加入进来。布莱斯和我六月份在英国参加过一个会议，基本上有一半的时间都是这样，我当时就觉得，这就是问题的关键所在：你知道演讲内容都会放到网上，对吧？所以如果你担心错过什么，其实不是因为演讲本身，而是为了人，而不是演讲。是的。
Uh, he made, um, it's like the strange loop infinity logo. And he basically set it up so that it had all of these leds inside that you could programmatically control they had like a little laptop and also a little midi keyboard so you could like play things and see in real time that like the leds change and try putting in little algorithms and make it animate so that um you can make like color patterns or uh or try to get like some design to to go around the loops it's really cool but overall i mean, I mean, uh, I, I hate to disappoint, but I, you know, if I was going to talk about a talk that really blew my mind, it was, um, I mean, Evan's talk was my favorite one, but I didn't watch very many of the talks because I was so
嗯，去听演讲确实有某些特定的原因。一个原因是，如果我和演讲者是朋友，我一定会去，以示支持。是的，但还有……如果我想向演讲者提问，我也会去；或者根据演讲的内容，我可能预料到自己会想问问题，那我就会去，因为当然了，你不能在线上这么做，那就太迟了。但如果你是事后观看的话，或者如果我觉得这将是一场会在会议上引起很多人讨论的演讲，那我就会想去，好了解一下当时的上下文背景。所以，观看演讲其实有点类似于和一群朋友在电影院看电影，部分原因是为了去获得在影院现场观看的体验，这和在家看是有所不同的。而且我觉得，看现场音乐会或是看现场演讲更是如此。不仅如此，甚至在此之外，你和大家一起走出影院，你们都在同时讨论刚才看到的内容，其中也有一些这样的元素。这也是我可能会去听演讲的另一个原因。是的，除此之外，我的想法绝对是完全一样的：无可替代的是人与人面对面的接触。我想这也是为什么我尝试过一些线上会议，但我真的很难投入进去的原因。线下会议确实是会议最大的卖点，能够亲眼见到大家并和大家交谈，而且那种随之而来的对话，在质量上完全处于另一个层面上。是的。
busy talking to people. I mean, that checks out. There's, there's many conferences that I've been to where there's, you know, I have a talk schedule and then you find yourself talking to insert person that you do not live in the same city with, and you are not going to have the opportunity to continue whatever conversation that you're having. And so, I mean, half, half the times you end up just being like, do you want to go grab a bite to eat somewhere? And then you're, you know, 50 minute hallway conversation turns into a three hour, you know, lunch or dinner, which then extends into like other people joining you i mean bryce bryce and i were at a conference in the uk in june and that's what happened like half the time where like literally i was just like well that's the thing is you know the talks are going to be
我敢肯定，布莱斯和我有着矛盾的心情，因为我看了亚历克斯·米勒（Alex Miller）的演讲。对于那些再次不太了解的人来说，亚历克斯就是从一开始就一直在组织 Strange Loop 的那个人，这基本上就是他的“心血结晶”。他做了一场演讲，讲述了他决定结束这个会议的原因。有很多原因，但其中之一就是……
online right so if you are worried of missing something like it's not actually going to be the talk it's going to be for the people not the talk yeah um yeah well there's definitely certain reasons that i'll go to a talk like one is if i if i'm friends with the speaker i'll always go just to sort of you know show support um yeah but also um if i want to ask the speaker a question um i'll go like if i or i maybe anticipate that i might want to ask a question based on you know the the content of the talk um then i'll go because of course you can't do that online it's like too late but uh like that is if you're watching it later and then maybe if i'm thinking that this is going to be a a talk that a lot of people are going to be
碳足迹。很显然，当你要把世界各地的人们聚集到某一个地方坐飞机参会时，对环境有着巨大的成本。我也一样，只要有可能，如果我有能力不坐飞机去某地，我就绝对不会坐飞机。但很多时候，如果你要去英国或者其他什么地方，坐飞机是唯一的选择。我真希望虚拟会议能……即使它们只有那种体验的 50%，就像你说的，那种对话的水平，也完全是另一个层面上的。而且我觉得这甚至不仅仅是对话，还有那些偶遇的机会，以及能够走到像吃豆人（Pac-Man）那样围成的圈子里加入对话的能力，无论是出去吃晚餐，还是之后的某种社交活动，不管有没有含酒精饮料。我记得十月的时候我参加了一个会议，是在锡拉丘兹大学（Syracuse University）位于阿迪朗达克山脉（Adirondacks）荒郊野岭的一个会议度假中心。你得从最近的城市开车大约三个小时才能到达那里。那感觉真是不可思议，因为基本上，这是一个为期两三天的单轨（single-track）会议，由于地处荒乡野岭，所有餐饮都是由会场统一提供的，大家都在一起吃早餐、午餐和晚餐。
talking about at the conference then i want to go just kind of have the context so you know that's there's an element of watching a talk that's kind of reminds me of watching a movie in a movie theater with a group of friends which is that partly it's to go and get the experience of seeing it in person you know in the theater which is kind of different than watching it at home and i would say it's even more true of seeing like a you know concert in person or seeing a talk in person um but even beyond that it's like you walk out of the theater together and you're all talking about what you just saw together at the same time and there's some elements of that too for that's like another reason that i would potentially watch a talk yeah but other than that like i'm definitely
最终发生的那些对话，简直让我觉得……我在虚拟会议或者 Zoom/Teams 会议里从来没有体会到过哪怕一点点接近这种感觉的东西。这就好比是一种并置或二分法：一方面，我希望我们能通过减少坐飞机来对环境造成更少破坏；但与此同时，我从来没有参加过哪场虚拟会议，其偶遇和体验能哪怕接近于被复制出来。我没有解决方案，我不知道该怎么做，我只是……我完全同意你的看法，那种对话，而且这甚至不只是 15 分钟的事，它是贯穿整个会议的。你会
of the same mind like the the thing that's irreplaceable is the person-to-person face-to-face contact and i think that's kind of why for me i've tried to do some online conferences but i just really have not gotten into them like in person is really kind of uh the main selling point to be of a conference is that seeing people in person and talking to them and the conversations that happen seem to be just on a totally different level in terms of yeah quality yeah i i i'm pretty sure bryce and i have like conflicted feelings because i i watched alex miller's talk who for those that are not once again in the know alex is the individual that has been organizing strange loop since the beginning and it's his basically uh baby and he gave a talk on kind of the reasons on why he was ending it and one like
在周一就开始聊某件事，然后在周三你就会冒出某种想法，接着再回过头来探讨它。不管怎样，我不知道你有没有什么宏伟的想法或解决方案，以后会不会有一个 Rock 会议？我是说，哦，你得好好想想该叫它什么名字。听上去你好像在说 Rock 或者是摇滚名人堂（Rock and Roll Hall of Fame）。我是说，我当然希望未来能有一个 Rock 会议，
there was many uh but one of them was like the um carbon footprint of like there's obviously a huge cost on the environment when you're getting a bunch of people that live around the globe to fly in somewhere and i also like you know whenever i can like if if i have the ability to not fly somewhere uh i will i will not fly uh but a lot of times if you're going to you know the uk or you're going somewhere you're not you know the the flying is the only option and i like i wish that virtual conferences know, even if they have like 50% of that, like the, like you said, like the level of conversation that you have, it's just on an entirely, and it's, I don't even think it's just the conversation. It is the chance encounters and like the ability to walk up to like, you know, the Pac-Man
但与此同时，我不认为我会是那个去组织它的人。A，这似乎是一件由社群来组织会更好的事情；但 B，我觉得我做会议组织者并不会成功。我会去做个演讲。这是一个吃力不讨好的职业，
circles and join conversations or, and the, you know, if, whether it's out having dinner or there's some social afterwards, whether, you know, there's drinks involved. Like I was at a conference back in October, um, at this, uh, like conference retreat center at Syracuse university in the middle of nowhere in the Adirondacks. And you had to drive like, you know, three hours from the closest city to get there. And it was just like unbelievable. The like, cause you're basically, it's a single track conference over two or three days and everyone's together eating breakfast, lunch and dinner because of the whole thing's catered because you're in the middle of nowhere.
而且真的很艰难。是的，这需要一套我不认为与我的技能有太多重叠的技能组合。是的，我是说，我对“线下”与“远程”持矛盾态度，因为……我曾共事过某些群体，他们在疫情期间对远程工作非常抵触。C++ 委员会当然就是其中之一，还有其他一些。天哪，我有多么希望能直接宣称：“这纯属无稽之谈。我们在远程能做的工作，和在线下能做的工作完全一样。”
And just like the conversation that you end up happening, it's just like, I have not gotten anywhere close in like a virtual conference or in like a zoom teams meeting. And it's like this or juxtaposition or dichotomy of like on one hand i wish we could you know harm the environment less by flying around but on at the same time like i've never been to a virtual conference where like those kinds of chance encounters and experiences have even come close to like being replicated and i don't have a solution i don't know what to do i just uh i completely agree with you that like those kinds of conversations that like and it's not even just like a 15 minute thing. It's like, it happens over the conference. You'll
但是，我想这可能并不是真的。或者至少，你可以把工作部分……
start chatting about something on Monday and then on Wednesday you'll have some idea and then you'll circle back to it. And anyways, I'm not sure if you have grand thoughts or solutions, if there's going to be a rock conference in the future. I mean, Oh, you got to think about what you're going to call that. It sounds like you're talking about Rock and Hall of Fame or Rock and Roll Hall of Fame. I mean, I certainly hope that there will be a rock conference in the future,
通过远程完成，但你无法通过远程完成工作中的社交和政治部分。科技界很少有人认识到并接受的一个现实是：在每一份工作、每一个职业、每一个行业中，人际互动都很重要，社群很重要，而且政治也会存在，这同样很重要。
but I also, I don't think I would be the one to organize it. That seems like, A, something that's, it's better if it's community organized anyway. But B, I don't think I would do well as a conference organizer. I'll give a talk. It's a thanklessless a thankless profession
所以，正是因为所有这些方面，面对面相处所带来的显着社交益处，我认为是很重要的。不过，我的意思是，在当今这个时代，这意味着如果我们面对面开会，那么面对面开会的主要原因之一，可能是为了建立这些联系、进行社交、让人们相互了解、开展合作，而不一定是为了……
and and really hard and yeah that has a requires a skill set that uh i don't think overlaps with my skill set a whole lot yeah i mean i i would say i'm torn on the the in-person versus remote because um uh certain there have been certain groups that I've worked with who were very resistant to remote work during the pandemic. The C++ Committee, of course, being one of them, but there are a few others. And boy, would I love to just be able to declare like, that's nonsense. Like we can, we can, you know, we can, we can do the same work, uh, virtually that we can do in person. Um, but, uh, I think that's probably not true. Um, or at the very least you can do the work part,
真正去干活。有些类型的工作，我认为在同步的面对面环境中效果更好，但有些事情天然就更适合异步的方式，比如如果你只需要某个人的某个意见或对某事的审查……发个电子邮件，让他们回复那封邮件就行了。是的，我同意。我有点糊涂了，听起来你好像有一半在为委员会的会议辩护，而我原以为我们俩都认为……他们刚刚在夏威夷开了委员会会议，这似乎是必要的。是的，没错。我是那个写信抗议我们在夏威夷开会的“坏蛋”。我是说，对于那些想继续去夏威夷的人来说，你是坏蛋；但如果你认为为了推进语言和库的发展，没有必要非得跑到夏威夷去集会，那你就是好人。如果我能找到的话，我甚至可以……我猜夏威夷并不是每个人所在位置的中点。没有。是的，就在你找那个的时候，布莱斯，所有其他语言（像 Rock、Swift、Rust 等等）都在使用 GitHub、异步协作，看起来一切都运行得挺好，而 C++ 却在苦苦挣扎，我是这么觉得的。然后他们去了夏威夷。
um, remotely, but you can't do the, um, the social and political part of the job remotely. And a reality that I think very few people recognize and accept in tech is that every every job every every career every profession um there are inner like interpersonal interactions matter um community matters and there's going to be politics and that's going to matter too yeah and so so because of all those aspects the um the the obvious social benefit of being face-to-face with people, I think is important. But I mean, I think in today's age, that means really that if we're meeting face-to-face, probably one of the primary reasons to meet face-to-face is to build those connections, to socialize, for people to get to know each other, to collaborate, not necessarily to
接着夏威夷会议之后，就传出了所有这些报道：“哇，我们在反射（reflection）机制上取得了进展！我们在契约（contracts）上取得了进展！”这就好像，“哦，原来缺的就是这个。一次夏威夷会议。大家只需要一点动力。”这就好，在所有地方里偏偏选了夏威夷——那地方对美国人来说交通就不方便，更别提世界各地的人了，什么鬼？我并不是想说这里面有什么邪恶的阴谋什么的，
actually do work. There are certain types of work that I think work better in a synchronous face-to-face environment, but there's other things that just are naturally a better fit for something asynchronous like if you just need need one person's like opinion or review of something um like send an email and let them reply to that email yeah i agree um i'm lost are you sounds like you're half advocating for committee meetings and i thought we were both like we they just had the committee meeting in hawaii seems necessary yeah yeah i'm i'm the bad i'm the bad guy who wrote who like like actually protested us having a meeting in hawaii i mean you're the bad guy for the folks that want to keep going to
但感觉在所有可以集会进行委员会工作的地点中，哪怕你是想在欧洲和美洲之间轮流举办，夏威夷也绝对排不上那些对环境友好、交通便利、或者让想要远程参与某种会议的人觉得时区合适的候选名单。不过，嘿，我没去过夏威夷。所以也许如果我去过的话，我的感受就会不同了，我会觉得：“你知道吗？那里的夏日微风和完美天气，让我这辈子从未有过如此清晰的思路和敏锐的思维。”我会把……我来读一下我发给 C++ 委员会的那封邮件。邮件上写着：“NVIDIA 认为，举办像 C++ 委员会会议这样的专业活动，却选择夏威夷科纳（Kona）这样的度假胜地，是非常不合适的，这也是为什么我们对将 2023 年 11 月会议定在科纳的 C++ 提案投了反对票。我们对科纳有以下几点具体的反对意见：第一，在度假胜地开会，让参会者更难向管理层证明差旅的合理性，也更难让管理层相信 C++ 社群会议是一个专注工作而非享乐的专业环境。第二，这是一个交通不便且昂贵的偏远目的地。第三，住宿和餐饮选择昂贵且缺乏多样性。第四，它处于一个不合时宜的时区（UTC-10），对远程参会者来说是一种惩罚，因为它距离任何主要人口中心都有好几个时区。”说得全都在理。
hawaii but you're the good guy if you think it should be unnecessary to convene in Hawaii in order to evolve the language and library. I'll actually, if I can find it. I'm guessing Hawaii wasn't the midpoint of everyone's location. No. Yeah. And it's just like, while you're looking for that, Bryce, it seems comical that like all the other languages, you know, Rock, Swift, Rust, etc. They're doing GitHub, asynchronous, you know, they seem to be doing just fine. And C++ is struggling, I'd say. And then they go to Hawaii.
这就是我的基本反对意见。我是说，归根结底，对我和对这件事的本质而言……我认为旅游胜地的某些特点，使得它们不适合举办专业的活动，即使活动包含社交也是如此，即使活动的主要目的就是社交。我想到的地方包括拉斯维加斯、奥兰多，还有夏威夷。第一，它会贵得多，因为有大量其他人是去那里旅游的。
And then out of Hawaii, there's all these reports. Wow, we're making progress on reflection. We're making progress on contracts. And it's like, oh, that's what was missing. A Hawaii meeting. You just, people need to be motivated. And it's just like of all the places hawaii like that's inconvenient for like americans to get to let alone like people around the world like what and it just i don't want to say that there's you know whatever some evil
我是说，拉斯维加斯可能会便宜一些。他们有很多比较便宜的会议中心，而且有很多会议都在那里举行。但同时，这就好像，你为你的活动挑选一家酒店、一个会场，在这些旅游胜地，那些酒店和会场的主要目标市场根本不是出差旅行的人，而是来这里消遣的人。你知道，科纳的那场委员会会议，多年来我们一直住在那家酒店——皇家科纳酒店（Royal Kona Hotel）。我们换酒店的原因是，有一年，NVIDIA（当时公司里有人担任两个不同子小组的主席）基本上向委员会表示：“嘿，这家酒店太糟糕了，我们 NVIDIA 将出资在另一家酒店订房间，我们将在那里举行我们的研讨小组会议。至于你们其他人可以留在这家酒店，但我们要走了。我们理解你们有合同在身，你们得留在坏酒店里，但我们不会待在那里。”委员会最终决定撕毁与那家酒店的合同。那家酒店到底有什么问题？嗯，我们被分配到的其中一个会议室竟然是在室外，周围各种东西的噪音污染极其严重，你必须使用扩音器才能让别人听见。然后有一次，有两组不同的人必须在一个室外房间里相邻开会。于是，你会听到隔壁人们说的一切。接着还有一些正常的酒店问题，比如某些房间里有霉菌之类的事情。不仅如此，每当我们去那儿的时候，
conspiracy or whatever but it just seems like of all the places that you could convene to do committee work even if you're trying to rotate it from like Europe to America, et cetera, like Hawaii doesn't make the short list of places that's like good for the environment, easy for people to get to, you know, time zone makes sense for people that want to tune in virtually for some sort of meeting. But, you know, hey, you know, I haven't been to Hawaii. So maybe if I had been there, then I'd feel differently. And I'd be like, you know what? It's that, that summer breeze and perfect weather. I'd never, I'd never had such clear thoughts and
都会遇到至少一场、甚至两场婚礼。所以你会看到，有些人花了 10 到 12 小时工作、社交、互动，然后想在正常的时间上床睡觉，结果却碰上疯狂的婚礼派对或其他乱七八糟的事情。如果我们要举行这类聚会，我宁愿把它们放在那些主要市场是专业活动或专业度假村的地方。
mental acuity in my life. I will, I will read the, the email that I sent to the C++ committee. The email reads, NVIDIA believes it is inappropriate to hold professional events like C++ committee meetings and vacation destinations such as Kona, which is why we voted now on the Insights C++ motion to host the 2023 November meeting in Kona. We have the following specific objections to Kona. Number one, meeting in vacation destinations makes it harder for attendees to justify travel to their management and convince them that C++ community meetings are a professional environment where we focus on doing work, not having fun. Number two, it is a remote destination that is difficult and expensive to travel to. Number three, lodging and dining options are expensive and limited in diversity. Number four, it is in an inopportune time zone, UTC minus 10, that is punishing for remote attendees as it is a few time zones away from any major population centers. All good points.
如果你想把会议开在一个风景优美的好地方，有很多不错的选择，我认为这些选择受到的反对会比夏威夷小得多。我甚至可以说，我和康纳每年都要去阿斯彭（Aspen）开一个会，我甚至可以说阿斯彭都要好得多。不是的。我没去过阿斯彭。我只在 2019 年去过一次，之后就再没去过了。
That's my basic objective i mean ultimately what it fundamentally comes down to to me is that um i don't think that there's certain aspects of a tourist destination that i think make it bad fit for a professional um uh event even if it's like socializing um even if the's like socializing. Even if the main purpose of the event is to socialize. I'm thinking places like Las Vegas, Orlando, or Hawaii too. One, it's going to be a lot more expensive because there's a ton of other people that are there for tours.
不过，你知道的，阿斯彭虽然也稍微有点难抵达，但它靠近一个主要机场，处于一个主流时区，我们去的时候那里既安静又美好，有专业的会议场地。当你想要远离人群时，它是一个开会的好地方。我认为举办活动的坏境确实非常重要，
I mean, Las Vegas might be cheaper. They got a lot of conference centers cheaper. Um, and there are a bunch of conferences that are, that are held there, but, um, but also it's like, you know, you pick a hotel for your, you pick a venue space and in these tourist destinations, those hotels and venue spaces, their primary market is not, you know, people traveling for work. It's people traveling for fun. You know, that Kona committee meeting, for many years, we stayed at this one hotel, the Royal Kona Hotel. And the reason that we switched hotels was that one year, NVIDIA, which at the time had people who chaired two different subgroups, we basically told the committee, hey, this hotel is so bad that we, NVIDIA, will pay to have rooms at another hotel, and we're going to hold our study groups there. And the rest of you can stay at this hotel, but we're leaving. Like, we understand you have a contract and you have to stay at the bad
而且，当你把活动放在夏威夷举办时，这其实是在发出一个相当强烈的信号。好了，在我们过渡到聊聊 Rock 之前，因为我们马上就要到 30 分钟大关了——我们通常会把这些切成 30 分钟一集的节目——请在 60 秒内告诉我，为什么这个会议还在继续？你写了抗议信……好吧，所以……抱歉，我漏掉了我发的那封邮件的最后一句话，那就是我基本上说过：“我们认识到，要更改 2023 年 11 月的会议已经不切实际，因为合同已经签署，人们也已经预订了行程等等。”我们提出这一反对意见是在会议召开前大约六个月到一年，然后在会议召开前六个月又提了一次。但我们……
hotel, but we're not going to be there. And the committee eventually decided to break their contract with the other hotel. And like, what was wrong with the other hotel? Well, one of the meeting rooms that we were given was literally outside with such bad noise pollution from everything around that you had to use like a loudspeaker to be able to be heard. And then at one point, there were two different groups that had to meet next to each other in an outdoor room. And so, you would hear everything that the people next to you would be saying. Then there were like some normal hotel problems like mold in some of the rooms, stuff like that. But then also every time we would be there,
我们在会前还是投了反对票，只是为了表达我们的反对态度，并劝阻未来不要在度假胜地举办会议。好吧。所以基本上我们两年后见，敬请期待。是的。NVIDIA 立场的 TL;DR（简而言之）就是：C++ 委员会应该毫无乐趣。
there would be at least one, maybe two weddings. And so you'd have people who spent 10, 12 hours working or socializing, interacting, and want to go to bed at a normal hour. And there would be some crazy, you know crazy wedding party or other thing going on. I would much rather, if we're going to have these sorts of gatherings, I'd much rather have them in places where their market is more professional events or professional retreats.
抱歉，就是……抱歉，但这真的一点乐趣都没有。我是说，我觉得你列举的那些要点跟乐趣毫无关系，它们关乎的是不便、成本以及能否高效开展工作的合适地点。我敢确定，如果你去问所有那些每两年能去一次夏威夷的人，他们会说：“你知道吗？我的工作效率达到了顶峰。在漫长的工作日结束后，这是个放松身心的绝佳地方。”但我敢肯定……
If you want to have your conference in a nice, beautiful destination, there's a ton of good places for that that I think are less objectionable than Hawaii. I would even argue, Connor and I go to a conference in Aspen every year. I would even argue that Aspen's better. It's not. I haven't been to Aspen. I only went there once back in 2019. I've been back since.
如果你想把会议办在一个风景优美的好地方，有很多我认为比夏威夷更合适且争议较少的好去处。我甚至可以说，康纳和我每年都会去阿斯彭参加一个会议。我甚至想说阿斯彭更好。其实并不是。我没去过阿斯彭。我2019年去过一次，之后就没再去了。
But, you know, even Aspen's a little bit harder to access, but it is near a major airport. It is in a major time zone. It's nice and quiet when we're there. Good professional venues. It's a good place for a retreat when you want to get away from people like the environment where you're going to hold an event i think really does um matter a lot um and uh uh when you hold your event in hawaii that sends a pretty strong signal all right so before we transition uh to chatting about
但是，你知道的，阿斯彭虽然交通稍微难一点，但它靠近主要机场，处在主要时区。我们在那里的时候既安静又舒适，有很好的专业场馆。当你想要远离人群时，它是一个举办闭门会议的好地方，我认为你选择举办活动的场情况确实非常重要，而且，呃，当你把活动办在夏威夷时，这释放出了一个相当强烈的信号。好了，所以在我们过渡到聊聊
rock here because we're coming in at the 30 minute mark which is we usually dice these up into 30 minute episodes in 60 seconds or less why is this meeting still happening like you you wrote the committee protested well okay so so i i'm sorry i didn't read you the last sentence of the email that i sent uh we which is that i basically said we recognize that it is impractical to move the 2023 november meeting because contracts have already been signed people have already booked travel etc this objection we made like six months a year before the meeting and then six months before the meeting but uh we we before the meeting. But, uh, we,
Rock 这里的议题之前，因为我们马上就要到30分钟大关了，我们通常会把它切成30分钟左右的单集，在60秒或更短的时间内解释一下为什么这个会议还在开？就像你，你写了委员会抗议。好吧，所以，所以，对不起，我没有把邮件里最后一句读给你听，呃，我们，也就是我基本上说过，我们承认要更改2023年11月的会议是不切实际的，因为合同已经签了，大家也已经预订了行程等等。我们大约在会议前六个月到一年提出了这个异议，然后在会议前六个月又提了一次，但是，呃，我们在会议前……但是，呃，我们，
we voted no just to express our objection and to discourage future, future meetings in vacation destinations. All right. So basically we'll see in two years, stay tuned. Yeah. The TLDR of, uh,
我们投了反对票，只是为了表达我们的异议，并劝阻未来不要在度假胜地举行未来的会议。好吧。所以基本上我们两年后见，敬请期待。是的，TLDR（太长不看）就是，呃，
of NVIDIA's position is that, uh, the C++ committee should be no fun. Um, uh, sorry, like. Sorry, but no fun. I mean, I think your enumeration of points had nothing to do with fun. It had to do with inconvenience cost and appropriate locations for being able to be productive. And I'm sure if you asked all the people that get to go to Hawaii once every two years, they'd say, you know, I'm at my maximum productivity. It's a great place to, you know, relax after a long days of work. But I'm sure,
英伟达的立场是，呃，C++委员会应该毫无乐趣。呃，抱歉，像是。抱歉，就是毫无乐趣。我的意思是，你列举的那些点跟乐趣毫无关系。那关系到不便、成本以及能够保持高效的合适地点。我敢肯定，如果你去问所有每两年能去一次夏威夷的人，他们会说，你知道的，我达到了最高的工作效率。这是一个好地方，你知道的，在漫长的工作日后可以放松。但我敢肯定，
you know, that's just because people like going, like having a company paid trips to Hawaii is probably what it is. Anyway, so if you do end up having, I mean, I don't think Rock is going to go the way of committee meetings, but if you do, Richard, you know, I'd steer clear of Hawaii. Otherwise, ADS be the podcast will come after you just as hard as the C++ committee. Speaking of which, and oh, yeah, also, too, this is, I think, technically going to be episode 156 that just wrapped, which is our three-year anniversary.
你知道，那只是因为人们喜欢去，比如让公司出钱去夏威夷旅游大概就是原因所在吧。总之，如果你最后真的去参加了——我是说，我不觉得 Rust 会走委员会会议的老路，但如果你真的去了，理查德，你知道的，我建议你离夏威夷远点。否则，ADS 播客也会像针对 C++ 委员会那样严厉地对付你。说到这里，哦，对了，从技术上讲，这刚刚结束的一期应该算是第 156 期，这也正好是我们的三周年纪念。
So, I mean, once a year, we usually ask folks, you know, you don't actually have to go give us a rating. I was just on Spotify the other day, and I saw we had a 4.6 out of 5 stars, which, off of 86 ratings, which I think is pretty good, you know? We'd love to be 4.7, though. But also, if you don't like us and you listen, feel free to go whatever, you know, I hate podcasts that say, go leave us five stars. It's like, well, what if, what if you don't think it's a five-star podcast, you know? So you leave whatever you think. And if you don't want to rate,
所以，我的意思是，一年到头我们通常会问大家，你知道的，其实你们不一定非得给我们打分。我前几天刚看了一下 Spotify，发现我们有 4.6 星（满分 5 星），这是在 86 个评分的基础上得出的，我觉得这挺不错的，对吧？不过，我们其实挺想冲到 4.7 星的。但是，如果你不喜欢我们却还在听，也随便你，你知道的，我讨厌那种总是说“去给我们五星好评”的播客。这就好比，万一，万一你觉得这不是一个五星级的播客呢？所以你想打几分就打几分。如果你不想打分，
that's fine too. So thanks for listening. We will do some three-year anniversary special, probably with Sean Parent, because he has some thoughts about our last couple episodes. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the things that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline day low quality high quantity that is the tagline of our podcast that's not the tagline our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那也没关系。谢谢大家的收听。我们将会制作一些三周年纪念特别节目，可能会邀请 Sean Parent，因为他对我们最近的几期节目有一些想法。请务必查看你的播客应用中的本期节目shownotes，或者访问 ADSPthepodcast.com，以获取今天节目中提到任何事物的链接，以及一个可以让你留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论区链接。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。“高质量不如低质量”，这就是——低质量、高产量，这就是我们播客的标语——不对，那不是我们的标语，我们的标语是“充满点缀着信息的混乱”。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。